- Hi, it's Rie.
Today, I've been challenged
to take a popular food
and Make it Fancy.
Today's challenger is Alix.
- Hey Rie, it's your best friend
in the entire world, Alix.
So today I'm gonna challenge you to make
one of my favorite candies
in the world fancy, M&M'S.
Last time I challenged you
to make Skittles fancy,
and you did an amazing job.
I figured that M&M'S are
like the chocolate equivalent
of Skittles.
I can't wait to see you,
I can't wait to see what you make me,
and remember to Make it Fancy.
(mischievous music)
- M&M'S, of course I've had it before.
I feel like it's a little
bit too sweet for me.
Good thing it's they are
little so you can stop
when you feel overwhelmed.
I'm gonna have a quick sample
since I haven't tried
this for a long time.
(M&M'S crunching)
I like the crunch.
First few bites are great.
Make your hands become rainbow.
Somehow I like brown one the best.
I want to make something
I've never made in this show before.
I got some great idea, and as always,
I'm excited to Make it Fancy.
(upbeat music)
All right, here's what I got.
Strawberries, apricots, vanilla cookies,
heavy cream, butter,
yogurt, avocado, almonds,
goat cheese, cherries, and milk.
From the pantry I got
flaxseed, cocoa powder,
maple syrup, sweetened
condensed milk, baking soda,
brown sugar, dark
chocolate, white chocolate,
cacao nibs, pistachio,
coconut oil, flour, salt,
powdered sugar, and brandy.
Okay, let's get started.
Make it Fancy.
(mischievous music)
First, combine dry ingredients.
I have one cup of flour, one
fourth cup of brown sugar,
one teaspoon of baking
soda, half teaspoon of salt.
Mix well with whisk.
And I have one cup of whole milk,
quarter cup of yogurt, mix well.
One tablespoon of flaxseed,
one tablespoon of cacao nibs,
quarter cup of pistachio,
half cup of dried cherry.
Since M&M'S had so many varieties,
I'm going to use peanut M&M'S for this.
I'm adding one cup,
and I'm using more different
kinds of M&M'S later.
- [Producer] Which do you
think was invented first?
The chocolate M&M or the peanut M&M?
- I think chocolate, right?
- [Producer] Yes.
Do you know the year?
- 1947?
- [Producer] 1941.
- It seems like a lot of--
- [Producer] All the good stuff.
- I was gonna say junk food
it's invented in 1940s.
The year of junk food.
Pour this batter in a loaf pan,
bake this at 350 degree for 50 minutes.
Cool down to room temperature
and freeze it for a bit.
So we baked, and cooled,
and put in the freezer.
The reason we put in the freezer,
it is easier to cut thinly.
There is a lot of hard ingredients,
like nuts and dry fruits in it,
so it's a little tough to cut.
If you have a sharp knife or a
bread knife, it will do well.
So lay them on the tray.
This is not like other pastry,
it's not like cookies, or cream puff.
So it doesn't expand,
so you can actually put
pretty close each other.
I'm going to finish cutting them.
Bake at 300 degree for 15 to
20 minutes until it dries out.
One cup of heavy cream.
So this time I'm using mini M&M'S,
'cause it will melt quickly.
Half cup, cook until everything melts.
- [Producer] M&M'S are the
most common eaten chocolate
in space.
- Kinda makes sense, right?
'Cause it's everybody loves chocolate.
I'm not interested going to space,
so the only thing you will
see it's like those planets
there it's not many things you can eat.
We are living in such a beautiful planet,
and we have so many choice,
you can eat whatever you wanna eat.
But if you are going to space,
you have to wear same
thing, and food is limited,
and there it's so many things
I haven't seen in this world,
then why go to space?
(Rie laughing)
Everything is melted in heavy cream.
Put this M&M'S and heavy
cream mixture into a blender.
This is smell like a nice hot chocolate.
I'm adding one avocado,
quarter cup of maple syrup,
two tablespoon of cocoa
powder, one pinch of salt.
I'm going to blend this.
(blender running)
And pour, cool this to room temperature
and chill in a refrigerator
at least 30 minutes.
One cup of heavy cream in a small pot,
10 ounce dark chocolate.
And now I'm using the regular
M&M'S, adding six ounce.
Two tablespoon of butter.
Mix it up.
- [Producer] Do you know
what their slogan is?
- Melting pot of chocolate.
- Milk chocolate that melts in your mouth
and not in your hand.
- It melts.
It's melt in your hand.
M&M'S doesn't need to be
melt completely for this one.
Take off from the heat,
transfer this into a bowl,
add three quarter cup of pistachio,
three quarter cup of almond,
three quarter cup of
crushed vanilla cookie,
two tablespoon of brandy.
Using spatula and mix
everything well combined.
Put this in a refrigerator
about 30 minutes
or until moldable.
Chocolate mixture firmed up,
so I'm going to divide this in half.
Put in a plastic wrap,
kinda shape it into a log.
Twist the corner.
And you kinda hold this
end, tie the corner.
Press against on a flat surface,
and make even thickness log.
I'm gonna do one more, put
the mixture in plastic wrap,
cover with plastic, tie the corner,
and press against flat surface
and make an even thickness log.
Chill this until completely
firm, about one to two hours.
Okay, so the chocolate
log it's completely firm.
Spread powdered sugar in
a sheet pan, and unwrap.
And cover with powdered sugar.
Brush off excess with pastry
brush, and I'm going to slice.
It has a lot of hard ingredients
like cookies and pistachio,
so instead of slicing like a saw motion,
you kinda press it and push
it down like guillotine.
It's this how guillotine work?
Probably.
(Rie laughing)
Just use the heel of your knife
and just use the gravity.
I'm going to finish cutting this,
and we have plenty more things to do.
I have double boiler,
adding one and half
cup of white chocolate,
seven ounces of sweet condensed milk,
and two tablespoon of butter.
Mix it until everything
is completely melt.
And I'm using double boiler
because white chocolate is easy to burn,
and also butter helps white
chocolate not get burnt.
So I have a greased container,
and I'm going to transfer this.
Ooh, nice texture.
Chill this in the
refrigerator about three hours
or until this become completely firm.
One cup M&M'S, add in a food processor.
(food processor running)
(Rie laughing)
We didn't expect they was
coming out from here, okay.
(food processor running)
This looks good.
Add in a mesh sieve and strain.
I just want to use this dust,
so I'm going to put bigger
bits in a separate bowl.
So this is the chilled
fudge I just made earlier,
sprinkle this dust over the fudge.
And you want to coat this evenly.
- [Producer] Are you a cheese snob?
- I am not a cheese
snob, I'm a cheese lover.
My Instagram account it's
thedessertsnob, but I'm not.
Am I snob?
(Rie laughing)
Maybe.
Put this in the refrigerator
until I'm going to use it.
We still have so many things left.
Double boiler going.
I'm adding six ounces white chocolate,
and one tablespoon of butter.
While it's melting,
I'm going to combine 6 ounces goat cheese,
quarter cup of powdered sugar,
and two tablespoon of milk.
My white chocolate mix
it's nice and melted.
Put this over to my goat cheese mixture.
Put half cup of mini M&M'S and
half cup of chopped apricots.
Fold them into white chocolate mixture.
So we are going to put
this in the refrigerator
about 30 minutes until moldable.
My white chocolate mixture
it's the texture I want it.
And I'm going to use plastic.
The texture you want it's
firm but not too firm.
You can mold it as you want.
So the texture you're
looking for is mashed potato.
I was thinking about we
were stretching on a break.
In Japan during summer break,
I don't know if the kids still do it.
We have to go to like a park
and do the exercise every day
at eight or seven AM.
And if you go there, you get a stamp
and you have to turn in to teacher
after the summer vacation.
- [Producer] Do you remember
what the exercises were?
- Yeah, like I still remember.
There's a lot of like this, and jumping.
(Rie laughing)
While I was exercising I
shaped it into a rectangle.
I'm going to put this in the refrigerator
about two hours until firm.
Meanwhile all of our
crews is going to exercise
for two hours.
One cup of dark chocolate,
and one cup of mini M&M'S crushed,
and two tablespoon of coconut oil.
Melt this completely.
Alix finally met my son.
She was super excited.
He is confused.
(Rie laughing)
But she is great with kids.
I was a little bit worried
that shell is gonna remain big
but it actually melted quite nicely.
So I'm not gonna use
blender, I was going to,
change the plans.
Take off from the heat,
dip the strawberries.
So this is classic chocolate
dipped strawberries,
but it has M&M'S shell in it
so it's going to have a nice crunch to it.
It might be a nice
surprise when Alix try it.
I added coconut oil into
this chocolate mixture
because it will hardened much quicker
than just using chocolate,
and it is much easier
than tempering chocolate.
Put this in the refrigerator
until chocolate hardens.
And we are going to make
something very exciting.
I'm going to start with chocolate salami.
Kinda make it look like a river.
Kinda wanna make it look a little natural.
So I want to show the inside,
so I'm gonna just cut the nice wedges.
It's just look like cheese, it's crazy.
(Rie laughing)
Gonna look like a Pokemon.
I think charcuterie board
is getting very popular,
'cause yeah, who doesn't like
a good charcuterie board?
And it's so fun.
Like there is a lot of things to eat.
I'm thinking about color and shape,
but mostly I'm kinda doing freestyle.
Most important thing is you
want to make the board full,
and also you want to put
odd number, not even number.
So I'm adding three piece
of chocolate dip strawberry with M&M'S.
And M&M chocolate dip, I have grapes.
I like cut up fig 'cause it's pretty,
and just put here and there.
Some orange.
Chocolate it's kind of dark and brown,
so I kinda want to add
some like pop orange
and other fruits.
Peanut M&M'S, think I wanna
just fill space with this guy.
Just having fun.
I think this is perfect
for Halloween for adults.
Like grown-up snacks.
So I have this cookies I'm gonna put here.
Apricots.
Wow this is fun board, I
want to come this party.
I'm inviting myself.
Finish with pretty edible
flowers, and we are done.
(whimsical music)
M&M charcuterie board, very fun and fancy.
Let's see what Alix thinks.
(upbeat music)
Open your eyes.
- Oh my gosh.
Is this a chocolate charcuterie board?
- Yes.
(both laughing)
- [Alix] Chocolate salami?
- Mhm.
- Oh my God, and what is this like a--
- It's a brie.
- You always know how to
do A plus presentation.
- Oh thank you.
- I wanna try one of
these and one of these.
I wanna try everything.
- Feel like cutting cheese too.
- You look like you're cutting cheese.
(Rie laughing)
You cut the cheese, eh?
Cheers, salami cheers.
Mm.
- Oh yeah.
- Wow, it's unique.
It's a little tangy.
Delicious.
I would've never paired goat
cheese and M&M'S together.
What is this?
Oh chocolate dipped strawberries?
I didn't even realize.
Oh, should we eat it like this?
Like we're in love.
(both laughing)
Mm.
- Charcuterie cheese board.
- Rie, charcuterie.
- [Both] Charcuterie.
- Rie made me a chocolate charcuterie.
And I say yay, 'cause it was really amay.
- Three, two, one.
- [Both] Make it Fancy.
- And dancy, ayy,
ayy,
ayy.
(Alix laughing)
(upbeat music)